- Welcome back.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you for having me back.
- Absolutely, we love you.
I'm always excited
when you're here.
- I love being here.
You make me and everyone happy, I think.
(audience applauds)
- Oh god, that's nice.
That's a really nice compliment.
You know, I gotta say this
too, I didn't realize,
even the last couple times we talked,
I didn't realized you created,
you're one of the creators of The Talk.
I thought you were just on
it at first. That's amazing.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah. (crowd applauds)
- I was like, "Damn okay, that's amazing".
- It was funny because I'm not really...
I was always really shy,
and I thought of this,
- That's funny.
- I know.
(audience laughs softly)
And I thought of this
idea for a talk show,
and I thought, I actually went
in to the network and I said,
"I'm worried you guys are gonna buy this,
cause I'm not sure
- How I feel
- I wanna view it", yeah,
I'm not sure how I feel.
- Dreaming big
- You when you're sort
of facing your fears
- Yeah
- and you know
when you face them, it's
gonna pick up steam,
- Yeah
- and that's what happened but
- And the idea sounds
amazing in your head,
but then you're like, "Oh
I have to actually do it".
- "Oh, I'm actually here", yeah, yeah
- Yeah. I'm like,
I can cover Cardi B and then
I have to do it and I'm like,
"What am I doing?"
(audience laughs softly)
That's my version.
- But it is liberating, right?
- It is.
- Once you face your fears,
- Yeah.
- it is empowering.
- I'm a little bit of a
comedian when I do it,
like I got to kind of do it that way
to pull it off, I think.
- Right.
- But it's fun though.
- But you do
- And I think
it's great though,
I find you very conversational,
so it's so funny
I wouldn't have thought
you were super shy.
- Oh, I like that
- Yeah, yeah.
- I've hidden it well for years.
- You're an actor though.
- There you go,
- So maybe you were acting.
- There you go.
(Kelly laughs) (audience laughs)